how do I reconcile a traditional Islam
with liberalism secularism and these
modern ideologies so I went and studied
philosophy and I became critical of
these ideologies like modern liberal
secularism humanism atheism these isms
and and that's you know the title of my
book basically they're a subtitle my
book is critiquing these isms that I
believe and through my study they're
destroying Humanity not just Islam but
just all of humanity is under threat
from these isms that are destroying
Human Society I hope we can talk about
that uh today by dedicated my career
basically to promoting this message
teaching Islam teaching how Islam solves
many of the problems and difficulties
that all people face in society not just
Muslims